don't be a stupid rapper stupid rap ism
that has somebody else tell them what to
do whatever you go do just do it for a
reason you know don't be a fool to sit
back and do it cuz somebody else started
I want to get in the game and get the
big house and the cars and put the pool
and I wanted to do all that and that's
one of the bad things about the game is
when you get launched even your friend
to turn against you where he
consistently ranks as one of the
greatest and most influential rappers of
all time when he released his debut
album ready to die in 1994 he became a
central figure in the East Coast hip-hop
scene he has certified sales of 17
million units in the United States he's
a notorious b.i.g and here's my take on
his top ten rules of success rule number
two is my personal favorite and I'm
curious if you wrote which one you guys
like the best and as always if he's
saying something that really resonates
with you please leave it in the comments
below and put quotes around it to other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
you
I'll take control you don't don't be the
type of rapper don't be a stupid rapper
a stupid rappers I'm that has somebody
else tell them what to do which is not
always wrong but if it's something that
you feel that you don't have to do you
really have to question it and find out
why they want you to do it mostly
because they feel like why you see what
Biggie's doing you know you have to hack
the can go and it isn't you'd have to be
like that but if you don't really want
to be like that you don't have to be
like that you know say a lot of just try
to tell them they got a to something so
quick and and give them examples of of
them that did it and blew up and make
them think that they can do the same
thing which is not always just something
true whatever you go do just do it for a
reason you know saying don't be a fool
to this sit back and do it cause
somebody else doing it because the one
thing you going to do is follow in
somebody else's footsteps you just gonna
be a shadow will be a shadow for the
rest of their life and I'll say if you
got a little sublet you know how to do
progress that it keep trying I mean God
knows what can happen you don't say
that's what I did
it's kept on rapid it's happened to get
to the right in its own sense oh man I
was just trying to do my thing man I
kind of lose what I didn't want to do I
didn't want to be that ghetto corner
rapper you know when I have my dreams of
getting in a game and wasn't just to get
in the game and still be on the corner
like you know I want to get in the game
and get the big house and the cars and
what's the pool and I wanted to do all
that you know and I know in order to do
that it certain things you have to do
with this away you go pinch it off in
this add your flavor to it
we linking up with pump the old familiar
to old tracks and I'm saying that's
going to get adult attention you know
saying it's just for lyrics it's going
to get the younger dudes attention so I
let them both I mean hey if they wonder
where to versace and the cool jeans and
the tangos and yeah biggie biggie and
all go with me I ain't got no problem
with it being a cat from Brooklyn and
just being on the corner I'm being able
to just spit something real quick and
just murder that whole circle you know
that's where you get your stripes and
yours
[Music]
No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
every way
flashy for nearly ready dies of the fly
all right just swung she trying to feed
on family joke don't say it's a job it
ain't nowhere somebody just felt like
doing I get it you know saying it was
hungry
everybody's gotta eat no saying I found
some I was good at I'm just trying to
flip it you know keep it going so I
ain't trying to slack at all purpose up
in my peoples my borough my family and
I'm hot I'm just trying to just be that
straight dude I don't went through so
much you know being in the streets or
whatever I'm been through so much my
mom's coming through so much it feel
good just have her at ease you know
ain't know how son is cool Keenan
streets doing no wrong he trying to make
happen
gotta still the positive vibe all my
peoples gotta stay on positive five the
negativity just brings failure you know
when you trying to fail in this game
we're trying to see is your family yeah
at this time I'm out here I mean I alive
at one point the music was more play
because I knew that if I did good music
I could take care of my family a lot
saw was more pushing towards making sure
the music was tight making sure every
show I did was right and just trying to
give as much money as I could so I could
take care of my family now that the job
was basically done to me I like I like
the live stuff there and stuff on the
album cuz stuff on the album see more
relaxed you know so you gotta have a
certain tone I'm saying puffy but I
don't get too excited she'll let it flow
but when you're on stage sweat pours
there I'm a big one too sweaty trench
I'll just be representing you all sales
doing my thing your necklace I'm going
up black night so when they want us
tonight
hello when I first heard Biggs done all
the first few bars a big demo I felt the
second coming of Big Daddy Kane I'm the
first time I heard I'm sorry's b.i.g was
from a demo tape that I got from Maddie
C from The Source magazine and I called
him I told him I was looking for some
new talent I want to something real real
raw and he said it's crazy but I have
something that's incredible the first
time I heard being was on the Supercat
record in the park it was dope to me
because you know when I I like super
Katy
I never heard could get out of home so
it was like a different voice a
different sound and it was flied to me
rustling the video scene when I'm saying
with love by PI's approach water like
you show up he's like he'd be a rapid I
would like to get to know me on tumblr I
mean we're big there was he simplified
you know the most intelligent things he
put him in laymen terms that people to
understand big was definitely likely
professor of how it should be done and
if you're a student a rap you got to
listen to him and is you can hit in
everybody's music and when everybody's
reciting big iran's me everybody
we say whatever he wants to say and and
it put together so well you know like
they say uh you can you can consider my
career like Mike's anyone tyson jordan
jackson action peg ridiculous i like
that that kind of like this is what
reference dude it like that and come
with that kind of thought
thought-provoking word plays far and few
in between I never seen him drop
anything down I've never seen him when
the sample was looped up he was just
sitting down there like I just eyes
closed and he would do this Matthew
thing was here like and then he just
starts spinning and I was like oh that's
sort of magic we've open every showing
doing warning it's the party of three
songs right now how much I use a dream
but you know how do people coming to get
you right is everything oh man that's
real fun
that's real yeah I'm exaggerating at all
that the more money you make the more
problems you get and jealousy and every
is this something that comes with the
territory where a lot of people this is
negative energy like my man Paul say
it's just surrounds you it makes you
depress you know so I got a rapper body
and that's one of the bad things about
the game is when you get large even your
friends are turning against you where so
I'm in some body for me how real is your
family people constantly coming in what
it's only I mean that's real nice Tommy
not I think about that every day
everything is real that's how real it is
I think somebody's trying to kill me
I'll be waking up paranoid
be really scared just be pero that's
just the way I am you know you seem
scared of death thank you guys so much
for watching I made this video because
Derek Taylor asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it down the comments
below and I'll see what I can do I'd
also love to know what did he say that
had the biggest impact on you on your
business on your life what change you're
gonna make after watching this video
please leave in the comments below and
I'm gonna join in the discussion finally
want to give a quick shout-out to John D
Webster John thank you so much for
picking up a couple of my book and
making that awesome YouTube video about
it I really really really appreciate it
ever inspired me to write my sixth book
which is a self-help book seriously love
that guy so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one where it is much loved
I'll see you soon